good morning John in the year 2000 I
lived in Florida and I voted in my very
first presidential election and the
decision between George W Bush and Al
Gore was decided by 537 votes in the
state of Florida in the wake of that
election which was so close that the
Supreme Court had to decide whether or
not to continue efforts to recount
ballots that were missed punched and
suddenly phrases like hanging Chad and
butterfly ballot entered the national
lexicon a lot of people cried fraud this
was made worse by a legitimate error in
a computerized election system that
counted a precinct with six hundred
voters as negative sixteen thousand
votes for Gore the glitch was caught but
seen by many as an indication or even
proof that election machines had been
hacked in favor of Bush possibly
intentionally with a plot between
Republicans and the manufacturer of the
machines as the CEO of that company was
a major Republican donor it just seems
like maybe not do that if you run the
voting machine company among my friend
group in college a lot of people just
sort of went on with their lives
assuming that the Republican Party had
defrauded democracy and that george w
bush was an illegitimate president but
we were like ultra lefty college
students al gore didn't say that none of
the Democratic leadership said that even
Ralph Nader the third party candidate
didn't say that everybody came together
decided we had a new president we had
done democracy we had done the American
thing and even if it had some flaws we
were gonna move forward together
president Trump doesn't talk like that
before the 2016 election he repeatedly
said that plots by the Democratic Party
were going to deprive him of victory
even after he won the election he said
he only lost the popular vote because
millions of undocumented immigrants
voted like it was it was just lies
because it sounded President Trump talks
like a political pundit and that's not
just a difference in style when you have
the power of the office of the President
of the United States behind you there
are things you shouldn't say because
they attack the foundations of the
country saying without any like
semblance of or even intention toward
proving it that that there's widespread
voter fraud funded by the people who
oppose you
that's like it weakens democracy that's
what President Trump has done it's what
he continues to do he's lied about
undocumented immigrants voting he's lied
about people in Pennsylvania voting
multiple times he's lied about people in
Massachusetts being bused up to New
Hampshire to vote the outright said
during the campaign the only way we can
lose is if they cheat the Republican
Party has long made the case that
individual people voting fraudulently is
a big prop a lot of people who know a
lot about this disagree with that but
that is the thing that they say and
they've used that for decades as a way
of passing laws that make it more
difficult for people to vote
particularly poorer people but the path
from that where like voter fraud is a
big problem - if I lose it's rigged it's
a pretty long path and also one that no
politician has ever walked down because
they're aware that that erodes the the
like faith in democracy it's literally
calling on your supporters to not accept
the results of an election democracy
works because people have faith in the
system but lies about voter fraud erode
that faith one of the government's main
goals should be to prove its own
legitimacy and if a leader is doing the
opposite of that it's hard to imagine
reasons for that outside of wanting to
retain power after losing an election I
don't believe that any leader is greater
than democracy and I think that very few
people in America do and that's the very
obvious reason why rhetoric like this
should be unacceptable to all of us John
I'll see you on Tuesday if you're in the
u.s. November 6th is the day a few
really great resources have popped up
this year to help you make sure you're
registered and to help you research the
issues and candidates in your area and
I've linked to them below